Speaker 1: The extreme Maga Q Anon conspiracy
lunatics are turning on Marjorie Taylor. GREENE
Why Marjorie Taylor GREENE voted for Speaker
Kevin McCarthy. She also said that the Q and on
stuff was just something she fell for on
the Internet. So now the real hardcore,
bonkers people are furious here. A couple of
callers to the Infowars conspiracy show with
which Alex Jones is involved. This was a
segment of calls hosted by Owen Shroyer,
and people are angry with Marjorie Taylor GREENE
now. Take a look at this. They are turning on her.
Speaker 2: Tom in California.
Tom, you're on the air.
Speaker 1: Go ahead. Go, Tom.
Speaker 2: They out. Let me get you off. You know,
I had you on speaker. I got to work. Unlike
the permanent underclass they're importing. Oh,
you have a job? That's right. So? Well, you are to
have a job, you bigot. You know what? Klaus Schwab
is going to make sure that you own nothing by.
Hey, I pay taxes. So I got a message for Marjorie
Taylor GREENE. She has a great voting record. But
guess what? It doesn't matter when she knows that
her policies aren't going to get through. Okay. So
here's the only vote that counts, and that is she
needs to change her vote. Today. Or she's a fraud,
okay? And she doesn't deserve to come on Infowars.
If she doesn't change your vote today. Yep.
Speaker 1: They are turning on her folks.
The vote for McCarthy. That is it. Here's
another caller who is also also furious
with McCarthy. Let's go with Marjorie
Taylor GREENE for voting for McCarthy.
Speaker 2: Josh in Arizona, Josh on the Alex
Jones show. Go ahead. Here we go. Amen. I just
want to echo with that last case. We had to make
a quick statement because he was going to work.
Cruz saying that you should ask Marjorie Taylor
GREENE if she's compromised to think something on
her business divorce. There's some things
going on with that because, you know,
it just kind of seemed like there was a major
flip flop with her. It was really weird, you know,
like she's all this going home and she's behaving
Kevin McCarthy all of a sudden and he's on the WEF
home page and like then speaker, majority owner,
something going on. And I just was wondering
if she could do me a favor and actually ask her
point blank, like, do they have something on her.
Speaker 1: Extreme suspicion now of
Marjorie Taylor GREENE the Q and on people,
the Infowars people, the frogs are
gay. People that follow Alex Jones
are now turning on Marjorie Taylor. GREENE How
quickly the tide can turn. But listen, obviously,
if you're Marjorie Taylor GREENE, you're going
to get more power by being friends with the
speaker than friends with the listeners of Alex
Jones show. That's an absolute, unquestionable
reality. So that is what's happening. And it's
funny and sad and scary all at the same time.